[Musique]
jean marc bonjour alors ça fait un an
qu'on aurait dû trouver une solution
alors qu'est ce qui bloque qu'est ce qui
empêche de signer un accord post briques
cité d'abord il reste combien de temps
il reste très peu de temps vous savez
les négociations ont repris hier après
midi et il vaut sans doute se poursuivre
aujourd'hui mais il reste quoi 24 heures
48 heures le brix il a été acté depuis
le 1er janvier 2020 c'est-à-dire depuis
le 1er janvier de cette année qui
s'achève là les anglais ne sont plus
dans l'union européenne
alors on reviendra pas sur cette
décision et morrison avait demandé une
période transitoire pour un an et
trouvez qu'il ya un accord qui permette
d'éviter un divorce brutal pour que ça
marche
eh bien il faudrait que cet accord soit
présenté à tous les parlements de
l'union européenne et qu'il puisse être
entérinée avant ce 31 décembre
donc si on ne trouve pas un compromis là
dans les 48 heures eh bien le 31
décembre on entrera dans un break seat
dure et le break 6 contreras avait en
vigueur avec des droits de douane des
quotas sans beaucoup de préparation
personne ne sait exactement comment les
choses vont se dérouler notamment à la
frontière notamment à l'europe tunnel à
l'embarquement des bateaux non ça risque
quand même est une pagaille noir alors
jean marc
qu'est ce qui bloque su finalement
écouté on a on a déjà réglé pas mal de
choses un problème de l'irlande les
droits sociaux des résidents des flux
financiers
on a beaucoup avancé mais il reste
effectivement trois dossiers trois
dossiers ça ils font mal le premier
c'est celui de l'accès des zones de
pêche vous savez les zones de pêche
britanniques sont très importantes ça
n'a échappé à personne
la grande bretagne est une île la
grande-bretagne empêche les européens de
venir draguer dans ses eaux pour les
européens c'est quand même difficile à
accepter parce que les zones
représentent à peu près 60% de leur
industrie sinon plus les zones
britannique pour aller pêcher vous êtes
obligés d'aller beaucoup plus loin en
dans l'atlantique il vers le sud sur les
côtes africaines et sahar coûtera
beaucoup plus cher le poisson sera
beaucoup plus cher alors on a un bras de
fer avec les anglais parce que s'ils
l'autorisent pas nos pêcheurs à
travailler la france l'allemagne le
danemark et un certain nombre d'autres
pays européens mettront leur veto à un
accord l'europe mettra donc des droits
de douane des quotas alors les anglais
garderont leurs poissons bien sûr mais
ils pourront pas les vendre alors ils
sont un peu aussi coincé
deuxième dossier concerne des conditions
de la concurrence et conditions
générales de la concurrence le royaume
uni veut continuer d'exporter ses
produits sur le marché européen c'est
très important c'est plus de la moitié
de son commerce
mais mais mais sans avoir à respecter
les normes sociales et normes sanitaires
les normes fiscales les normes
environnementales qui ont été mises en
place
du temps de l'union européenne l'europe
ne peut pas accepter que la grande
bretagne devienne ainsi un paradis
fiscal et puis une plateforme
d'exportation pour un peu tout et
n'importe quoi c'est la crainte donc là
encore on fermera la frontière avec des
droits de douane avec des quotas et une
troisième dossier concerne le règlement
des différends si demain il ya un litige
entre deux entreprises entre deux
partenaires et bien les européens
considèrent que ce litige sera jugé par
des instances européennes britanniques
sont pas d'accord puisqu'ils ne
participe plus à ces instances il
voudrait que ce soit les tribunaux
britanniques alors c'est quand même très
bloquée sur ces trois points l'ipo rit
jaune sol a finalement accepté hier
après-midi de revenir à la table des
négociations donne ya peut-être un petit
espoir alors boris johnson ça veut dire
qu'il peut cv ben ça veut dire que
beaucoup d'entre eux précise en
grande-bretagne voudrait qu'il cède à un
peu parce qu'ils lui ont fait dire qu'un
break site sans accord allait quand même
perturbé beaucoup la situation
économique alors la situation économique
est supportable en début d'année mais
depuis elle a été très abîmée par la
pandémie alors peut-être veut-il une
solution de compromis pour éviter
d'ajouter de la crise à la crise mais
vous savez boris johnson est assez
imprévisible
il ne croyait pas la gravité du comique
non plus il est quand même obligé de
l'admettre
merci beaucoup je remarque pour toutes
ces précisions pour tout cet éclairage
jean marc sylvestre éditorialiste sur rt
france